in five four three two one
what's going on you filthy animals
welcome to another episode of genius
brain podcast I'm trying to soundproof
this room a little more but on this side
I definitely have to put curtains here
put some [ __ ] there and some other [ __ ]
there
but that should cost money and none of
you guys can see it anyways work for it
so we have edrick back here on this
podcast what's up yo stupid ass do the
noise you always [ __ ] make alright
guys so I'm not even gonna do anything
else except the noise tell me what this
sounds like
[Laughter]
just me calling a dog in the gutter he
thinks it's something perverted but I'm
just like dude that's not you mixing a
paint you [ __ ] disgusting painter do
you so [ __ ] dumb you know I was
thinking about the other day yeah and
the only reason why I bring you on this
podcast so we could talk about this [ __ ]
about your poor life choices about one
woman that you should have kept in your
life I have never oh my god we're gonna
go there we're gonna go there yeah I
have never been so disappointed in
somebody's life choices until I met you
but for me honestly when people do
things that I don't agree with normally
I don't care yeah just because like it's
their life it's your life you do
whatever you want with it but you made
the biggest mistake of your life alright
well okay I think I made a good decision
oh yeah because it's you know morally it
makes sense financially it doesn't
alright so a little bit of background
information here who he's referring to
was somebody that I dated who was let's
just say she came from a very wealthy
background right you know let's just say
let's just say she could have been the
princess of Persia she could have fed me
and you taking care of my whole family
and it wouldn't have dented anything in
her [ __ ] big account that's true
that's true but long story short
basically it got to the
where she kind of gave me like in a
ultimatum of like you know three-year
plan of okay within the next year I want
to be married within two years Oh No
within one year she wants to be engaged
within two she wants to be married and
within three she wants to have kids how
long were you guys together before this
ultimatum came around though um I don't
know like year and a half or so or I
don't know two years our bid was enough
time I wasn't really keeping track no
but like for me is I don't appreciate
when somebody imposes their will on me
like that because it was just more of a
situation of now okay I told her I said
I can't make any promises because even
if I do I don't know what's gonna happen
from now until you know next month next
year two years from now all I can say is
I can say if we keep going down the path
that we're going down then that's what
it'll probably lead to but but she
wanted definite yeah yeah it was like I
want you to tell me that this is what's
gonna happen and I'm like I can't tell
you that nobody can tell you that who
the [ __ ] knows what the future holds for
us so you weren't you weren't sure that
that was the woman that you wanted to
marry even after you found out that she
was a crazy rich Asian do basically
that's the story she was like she was a
crazy she that's what that's where she's
from yeah yeah I mean but but the thing
is is like you know I think initially
when we first started dating she was
trying to not make it so obvious she's
trying to kind of hide I would have
never known oh yeah I absolutely was
super like down-to-earth yeah very sweet
yeah yeah and like to me when I met her
the the couple of times I would have
never thought that she came from money
because number one she didn't flaunt it
right
she didn't behave as somebody who came
from money so like yeah when I met her I
thought she was just some average girl
that's just working out obviously yeah I
mean I I really thought the same thing
and in the sense of like I didn't know
she came from that type of money and I
feel like she kind of had her
experiences with that where people would
try to use her or or like get to what
are you saying Rob why you looking at me
this is your fantasy that we're talking
about through me right I don't even
remember her name I don't care about her
name remember I just I just saw his
[ __ ] what do you call I call her
lotto
it's your winning lotto ticket that I
got after the fact oh by the way I found
this out after the fact I had no clue
and then he said this is the worst
decision that I've ever made him my life
no but I mean here's here's the thing
man is um I told you about this too is
like when she had brought up that
conversation is when we were preparing
the lookbook shoot for secret society
that was so a lot of [ __ ] was going on
and you know we had a pretty ambitious
project with that so in order to get
everything organized and make sure that
everything was gonna be what we were
hoping we could make there was a lot of
time energy that went into that but for
her even knowing that that wasn't the
best time to talk about it and she even
prefaced it by saying that like saying
yeah I know this is not the best time to
bring this up to you but and then blah
blah blah and I was like this is
something this is something else I gotta
get solved all of our problems she could
have so we were struggling so bad
I believe she even offered yeah she did
to help financially support it and she
hold on a second this is what she said
that got me the most this is where I
started to hate you as a human being she
said you could take whatever and you
don't even have to pay me back and I
said wow what a saint and you said I'm
leaving you are a bad person no I mean
here's the thing man it's just you know
as as a man as a principled man you know
it's just I there was no way that I was
even willing to entertain that idea or
that offer it was just more from like
for me it was just like I appreciate the
the moral support and and the thought
that you have
that that you would even be willing to
offer that but I made that very clear is
like there's no way that I'm taking your
money
you know for any reason and all I really
need is for you to be in my corner and
just give me the moral support damn dude
you sound like a fruity ass move weather
what a great choice would have been okay
I wanted in cold hard hats and I want
Jace to support my really good friend
David because he stopped doing YouTube
for two years and he still has the same
spending habits and then he's gonna live
with this and all he has to do is clean
toilets and make food that's it yeah I
mean but you know it is what it is man
like but was the ultimatum the only
reason why you didn't want to be with
her just because because like that that
was kind of like I think it showed me a
different shade of her then I had him
previously seen and and that was like
her kind of and this is this is how I
feel maybe she felt differently about it
but I just felt that she was kind of
saying what mattered to me was not as
significant as what's important to her
right now you know because the thing is
she could have waited like literally a
couple of weeks a month whatever to have
that conversation once we got finished
with it at least then she knows okay
that's off my chest that's off my mind
now we can have this conversation
which would I what I felt would have
been more reasonable but in the thick of
it when I would cuz cuz look at this -
man you know that when I I quit my job
to start this [ __ ] right yeah and then
so I was living off my savings and it
was obviously getting pretty tough right
now and so I was trying to really
conserve my money not go out be indoors
all day just [ __ ] working on this
[ __ ] talking with the factories whatever
and then it really started to take a
toll on me and then on top of that we
had to look book shoot so and you know
that that sure was no easy task either
man there were so many moving parts to
that so like she knew all of this was
going on because we would talk obviously
you know we're too
for that long but still heard desire and
her needs
pretty much outweighed all that and it I
almost took it as an indirect way of her
telling me like yeah I know that's
important to you but it really doesn't
matter because this matters more right
now
you know because what difference would
it have made if we had that conversation
two weeks a month two months even after
the fact right because we were already
together for a while at that point but
yeah I mean I'm sure I have my thoughts
and my feelings about it and she might
disagree with what I'm saying right now
but really doesn't matter I feel like
what happened happened for a reason and
I have no regrets about it you know I
have a great you were thinking about the
life of private Jetson I miss her I miss
you so much I miss you so much
Tiffany names start with s ah Stephanie
I I won't say I would say okay we can't
say her name yeah yeah just for just for
privacy reasons but [ __ ] hell well I
only met her a couple of times
that's this girl inside I like and she
had a heart of gold and she would this
she did she was with you you trash bag
she had a heart of gold dude oh man I
miss her so much dude I remember the
times where she and I just sat across
the table didn't talk [ __ ] what great
dude and she'd say hey I'm like hey and
then we'd be like what's up but I don't
know man I feel like everybody has their
own agendas and priorities in life you
know and at that point for me it was
about the brand I'm not gonna say that
she didn't matter to me in my life give
us buddy for the brand you didn't care
enough about the brand I know that and
hey you know I'm kidding dude I I'm not
gonna say this on the podcast but I I
got pretty kind of fed up with with that
her like offering me yeah I know what
that feels like though just because
I'm pretty sure in her case she wasn't
thinking like Oh like I need and her she
was proud she was trying to be helpful
mm-hmm but there's something about being
able to do stuff on your own with your
own will in your own power and your own
money yeah like it doesn't feel the same
and it almost feels like a handout you
don't want a [ __ ] hand exactly man
exactly I mean that's and I wasn't
raised like that you know what I mean
like you know our family didn't we
weren't rich we were [ __ ] poor so I
had to work for everything that I wanted
in life yeah that's just the way I'm
built you know and so I threw that all
away I remember a dress girl had really
big titties and I could have and I could
have lived in those oh my god I would
have just I wouldn't I would have just
[ __ ] held my tongue and just rested in
those balloons and you could have
floated away to happiness a rich man a
very rich man who didn't have to do
anything but not a woman you know what
the thing is though it's like she would
talk to my friends like because she in
her mind could not figure out why I was
so reluctant to give that type of
commitment that she wanted so she would
go to my friends and like kind of and
you know that she knows if she talks to
them about it that they're gonna talk to
me about it you know what I mean course
yeah default exactly so she would kind
of go to them and be like yeah I don't
understand why you know Edie doesn't
want to commit like that because you
know we we get along and you know like I
have money and I'm like if we get
married then that you know that would
also be his like what's mine is his but
I think from the very beginning I made
it so clear like I don't give a [ __ ]
about how much money you have yeah it
seems like for her she's probably used
to that type of treatment and it's kind
of interesting in her case where she
doesn't want to be judged or develop
relationships for that before that's her
trump card right so that's exact dude
that's the thing man at the end of it I
felt like she was almost hanging that
[ __ ] over my head it's like why wouldn't
you want to be yeah
yeah exactly she's talking to the wrong
person yeah and that I got [ __ ]
insulted by that I'm like dude said that
to me you do it like let me think about
it
right where she said this [ __ ] listen I
don't get it yeah what's mine would be
yours well why don't you save the first
pitch hey yeah I would have said yes a
long time ago why buy the engagement do
you buy your own give it to me and I
surprise you with something you already
know that I have because I can't buy you
something really and then you buy the
house right and the car and then you go
to work and then I put a ribbon on the
house and you didn't know and I cut it
saying it's happy about that I don't
know how this relationship works out but
I'm willing to figure it out I'm making
sacrifices so yeah I'm gonna be a
stay-at-home dad don't you worry about
six-pack I don't give up hey you know
what man like teach their own I know
some people out there can live like that
I can't like if I don't have that type
of like drive and ambition in my life I
just would feel like it's just hard to
end up being with somebody that you just
don't click with in that sense yeah yeah
cuz at the end of the day man we always
talk about this until you can leave with
the money that you have on this earth
anyway so what does it [ __ ] him exactly
and for me it's like what matters more
is about really doing and trying to
accomplish something that's meaningful
to me and like I was saying at that time
in place and especially in our
relationship I would have hoped and even
assumed that she would understand how
important it was to me especially
because she even made an offer member
about moving to her home countries right
yeah the biggest offer yeah and I said
if you know me you already know what my
answer to that is cuz we just started
the clothing brand - at that point yeah
no no it was right before that it was
wrong or no no I'm sorry I'm sorry I
think it was just yeah after we launched
it yeah I think I think that's what it
was I don't know the timelines Luisi
from the time we'll the point of that
was that during that time like she
should have known like yo I just started
something that I'm very passionate about
yeah you know I'm not gonna leave it
exactly and and to know the sacrifices
that I made for it you know what I'm
gonna bring David with me like they even
deceive an offer that put on the table
like so you're gonna get David place to
write like yeah I can come Mariel speak
Taiwanese Mandarin like she needs a
place this is the boat that you miss I
know that's a great film is called the
boat I miss the boat that you miss and
it's not even about the but like I said
this listen let me get a number bro let
me do it like a jackass poor choices no
I mean it's just like you know once once
I'm done it's done like there's there's
no cuz here's the thing man yeah and I'm
sure you can attest it as to is like
when a relationship ends right
especially if you guys didn't start as
friends trying to kind of now go
backwards into a friend zone and trying
to find that and establish that and
define that no my I saw your vagina we
can't go back I saw your vagina it's not
it's it's like inevitable accelerating
the inevitable just fast-forwarding it
you know like let's skip all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and just boom it's
gonna be done anyway yeah you I feel a
lot of people don't understand that
though yeah a lot of people say well
that's kind of heartless for you to cut
ties with somebody that you develop the
relationship over for for many years or
whatever months and stuff right but for
me is how I see this is if I die
tomorrow you would still move on right
right right
alright you would you would end up with
somebody else you'll have kids and
you'll eventually forget about me you're
right and so whether I choose to be a
part of your life or not your life will
still be better without me so it doesn't
matter that's what I'm saying ultimately
in the grand scheme of things it didn't
work out for a reason
and that doesn't mean that you need to
put your life on pause now
I mean sure take your time to [ __ ] go
through all the emotions of being sad
angry
ever but yeah like you said you are
gonna eventually move on and just the
difference with me is I don't really
believe in kind of dwelling on that
what's already done it's like alright
it's [ __ ] over with now yeah exactly
I got things that I need to focus on
when you're with that person you're
choosing to make the sacrifices with
like time and energy to dedicate towards
them but then once they're not part of
that picture anymore
so I do I got other [ __ ] that will
quickly take up that time I got friends
- you got friends now dude yeah we're a
no saw your vagina that's all I'm gonna
picture now and it's just like oh I
can't I can't do that yeah because it
was like at the end of it there was kind
of like well maybe in the future you
know there well there might be a
possibility and I said absolutely not
that's tight though that's good yeah
that was it that I would've been like in
the future no for me I I wanted her to
recognize what I'm saying is what I mean
right now I'm not just saying this
it's like string her along either no
absolutely not man like for her sake and
for my sake is I just now move on ice
and the best way I could put it is you
do you and I'll do me
that's pretty much what it is now there
is no us there is no we
right now it's our lives are separate
and we just got to go our separate ways
and it's like yeah in the future who
knows what would happen but I'm telling
you it's very very very very unlikely
that's like that's what that because I
don't like to move backwards if I move
beyond something it's usually for a
reason
I'm not gonna say that there's never
been something or someone where it was
like well maybe that could have worked
out at a later point in life at once we
may be more mature or more experienced
whatever but yeah for the most part it's
just like what's done with is done with
right it's it's odd some people just
value I don't know if they I don't want
to say value but they feel like a lot
any kind of significant moment in their
life is worth holding on to forever yeah
I don't really believe in that I'm more
like I'm like Marie Kondo with those
things it's like you Spock enjoy any
more time or you delete that's the
create Marie Kondo
but I don't but that's what I believe
anyways especially when it comes to
those type of relationships it's like
it's it's served its purpose I thank you
for it you thanked me for it and and
then we can move on and everything's
fine dude
yeah it's just it's just I don't I just
don't want it around I don't want
everything about it either I don't wanna
come on why would you want to think
about it when it's done with already and
then you get with somebody and then we
have to go to this whole motion of Oh
who's this guy well I used to suck his
dick quite often you know now I don't
suck it anymore yeah he saw my vagina
multiple times that's what I that's what
I think anyways I'm like when I see that
guy I'm like you don't know but i nutted
on that face multiple times and every
time you kiss her to sleep just just to
let you know you're also kissing my
children that I do it wasn't Colgate
hope you know that was my canvas before
and I just sprayed and prayed yeah but
all right any of you guys going through
breakups right now or towards the end of
your relationship whether you're young
or a little bit older just realize it's
not the end of the [ __ ] world
you know just learn to move on from it
because you have so many things you're
gonna experience so many other people
you're gonna meet and you got to really
open yourself up to that you got to
allow yourself to experience that
because if you just hold on to your past
and dwell on it and like just I don't
know be miserable in it then you're
depriving yourself now of potential
happiness future happiness whatever that
may be it might come in the form of a
person it might come in the form of a
job a hobby whatever that may be but the
only way to get past it is to recognize
that it's the past it's not it's not
part of your present it's not part of
your future anymore
also too if you ever meet a Taiwanese
girl that's loaded beyond beyond your
wildest dreams I'm talking about you or
Slumdog poor and you meet this girl with
very large titties that said you know
what what's mine is yours you [ __ ]
say yes do you push all those feelings
aside and his surface is up like you
have acid reflux then you take that
pepsin and you push it all the way down
till it dissipates trust me I've buried
a lot of pain in my life and I will bury
that pain again just to have a gajillion
dollars in my bank account you know what
guys ignore everything whoo
they've said you know go for that money
and go for those titties because it
cannot steer you wrong I just I don't
remember her name and I'm so sad and to
be honest with you I don't remember her
face yeah I mean you guys met like twice
you know in like a short period of time
but I do know she was very very sweet
she was that right I mean I don't want
to get too deep into it but that was I
think one of the things that I think
attracted me more to her was the fact
that once I did learn of the type of
background she came from the fact that
she was still that down-to-earth and
that sweet you know cuz yeah she was -
she wasn't in a flashy car I think she
had like a like a 3-series or some [ __ ]
right for ya like a serious I mean yeah
I know for a lot of the whole force but
in LA that's a pretty common car so yeah
and mind you the type of bomb that we're
talking about she wouldn't be rolling in
the for series right so like for me when
I saw it's like I would have never
guessed I would have never guessed
because if I had that money dude I'm
[ __ ] I'll get a magic carpet yeah I
don't even know if it exists but I had
the money to figure it out at least a
jetpack
I would I would dress as a sultan
that's so tan from Aladdin but you know
what man like seeing now I don't want to
over generalize here but that's the
thing like a lot of people who come from
that type of money and that type of
wealth they're always like second
guessing the people around them and
they're not 100% sure about who their
friends are
they're always second guessing people's
intentions or if they have some you know
hidden agenda of why they would want to
talk to them or even befriend them or
get with them so like I don't know dude
I just heard case two if that's how she
felt she should also take a certain
level of personal responsibility because
even how she was trying to solve your
guys's relationship problem was with
money the thing that she said that she
didn't like how people um judged her on
and also how she developed or people how
people would try to develop
relationships with her right but for her
I mean to no fault of her own that's how
she grew up yeah yeah so it's hard for
her to escape that cyclical habit yeah
it's just constant yeah you know it so
like I would see this a lot to where
I'm not sure if people have the
intention to befriend a rich person
because of that but what will happen
it's like I don't know they'll go
through some problem they'll just give
me money
yeah and that becomes like a habit right
and they start to develop this pressure
oh this person has my back but really
it's more like this person has excess
money and they'll just spend it why not
exactly and and I think a lot of the
times too you see situation of when the
families are wealthy and like the kids
are going through some [ __ ] the parents
will just throw money at it
yeah go buy this you know that'll take
care of it but it's like money's not
raising the [ __ ] kid you gotta be
there as a parent you know you got to
teach them the between what's right and
wrong and give them life lessons or at
least talk to them about what they're
going through don't just throw [ __ ]
money and a lot of times those kids in
the [ __ ] up right you know they
[ __ ] have no sense of or value of a
dollar and they spend recklessly some of
them get super into like partying
enjoyed I think that's probably the most
common thing we see like in LA they're
just super into like partying and drugs
and just [ __ ] spending money that's
that part those kind of people have to
constantly look towards like some kind
of chemical to make them feel something
right they don't know what that feels
like without it yeah because there's no
challenge exactly that's what I like
when everything is served to you on a
[ __ ] gold platter not even a silver
plaque a gold platter and it's like
everyone around you or yes men and yes
women I mean you're gonna seek ya
fulfillment and feelings and things in
the most superficial way possible right
and sadly a lot of times drugs can do
that for you it can it can take you it
can alter your mind and your feelings in
a certain way where that's just [ __ ]
scary dude yeah yeah it is and that's
why a lot of people [ __ ] go down a
very dark path because of that and for
us looking on on the outside you like
dude you got all the [ __ ] money in
the world man like you could get
anything you want why would you put
yourself in that position you want to
feel something I wouldn't know what it
feels like to be you poor guy oh I know
what it's like to look at a menu and
look at the numbers I don't even do that
I just pointed it and I buy it oh yeah
so just give me everything on this side
tell me when you were in Taiwan with her
that when you went to go eat something
her parents were wondering why you
weren't ordering Morris because you you
had your fill with the food like oh just
or just try it yeah tryna will throw it
away yeah yeah what kind of yeah what
kind of gobbling
yeah it wasn't a cheap restaurant either
so like for me I already ordered you
know what I was gonna eat it had the
[ __ ] Amazon pink dolphin sliced up
and the most endangered [ __ ] yeah and
you know I don't need a lot so I was
like oh [ __ ] I don't even know if I'm
gonna finish do does the most [ __ ]
annoying thing by the way I got to stop
this for a second thing that pisses me
off and I know I shouldn't get mad at
this but it's [ __ ] stupid so you know
when you go out to eat right there's
this concept called leftovers now what
does it leftover to most people leftover
is basically where you have a meal and
when you take it home because there's
enough to suffice it to be another meal
like it's gonna be sufficient
I've seen this [ __ ] ask for a
to-go box for a square of waffle Hey and
like and like and like you know when you
get a fried egg and you just had that
one egg white just fall off to the side
and that he asked for that puts head in
there and then there'll be like a tomato
seed and then he'll take that NATO seed
and then put that on top and he says can
I get it to go box please you eat that
[ __ ] on the spot you don't get it to go
box for that okay to be fair guys I know
exactly what he's referring to the
moment I had a still a whole pancake and
there was literally like one bite on top
because you know it's like a stack of
pancakes and I think I ate like a crock
it was a crumb yo I don't get mad and a
lot of my friends I've never been so
pissed even like Dave was so mad because
he's like dude just eat that [ __ ] it's
one more bite and I was like no I'm good
not in here what this trash bag did to
the next morning I wake up to it
reheated it
the he ate it for breakfast I was so
funny bad but but you know what because
I don't eat a lot and I don't like I
don't like to waste food I try to eat my
leftovers I would say probably four out
of the five times I have I take
something to go I
eat it I don't like to just take it and
throw it away I know a lot of people
just do that because they don't want to
be wasteful and they end up throwing
that [ __ ] away but no I actually eat
that [ __ ] bro that's why I want to show
you I was like I did this for [ __ ]
yeah you should have ate that on the
spot man like even though waitresses
will yes she goes like can I get this to
go she's like what err take that with
you just breathe it in your nostrils and
exhale it out what do you want to go
that that reminds me of the story of the
other ed though oh good yo so this this
this story might not be as funny when we
tell it but it's way funnier just
because of what happened so there's this
artist out there named Travis Garland
during this time our really good friend
Dan was shooting a music video for him
yeah and then we drove all the way out
to Lancaster for this in mind you this
was an overnight shoot it was on a
budget but you know we you know Dan made
it work and it was pretty amazing so I
was doing the the BTS photos for it and
all that other stuff we had a stay awake
I was on like four red Red Bulls and
like two animals and everybody was wired
up right and so in Lancaster on the way
back that was actually this like
Southern Comfort restaurant diner on the
way back now this is the funny part dude
so everybody's eating and mind you and
lost a lot of weight reasonable he was
fat as [ __ ] just like I was yeah and
this dude he eats his food and as he
goes you know what dude I can't have
another bite and this will shoved an
empty bowl to us with with just a
chicken he goes I can't have another
bike what you have nothing there that
[ __ ] look like an archeological dig
there was nothing was just [ __ ]
chicken I can't have another bite
there is no bite and we started dying
laughing
the funniest part about this [ __ ] wasn't
even that we weren't laughing so [ __ ]
hard and couldn't breathe and he started
progressively getting angrier he goes
well I don't get it
he's like and I love this dude is like I
don't because I don't understand why me
being the butt of the joke is so funny
but because he was getting angrier we
kind of laugh even harder
I don't think I've laughed that hard
ever in my life I I mean it's like the
fact that he didn't understand why it
was it's like brothers literally nothing
you can't eat a chicken bone you can't
shoe that [ __ ] I say I can't have
another bite usually their species is
spooked over yeah and he you know he was
fat like me so it was like a really fat
guy that ate every baby but he slides a
empty bowl you gonna eat the chicken
bones
exactly that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny
man see but the difference is that when
I say I can't all right here's the
difference though is I don't I told you
man like my doctor said don't eat until
you feel full because you're not gonna
do yourself any favors because of my
acid reflux so I get to the point where
I feel like satiated like okay you know
what that's good and then I stop myself
because that one extra bite could take
me over now to a point where I didn't
enjoy that meal as much as I could have
if I just stopped there so that's why
that it's maybe like a hundred and six
pounds haha
actually you know what man I've gained
weight in my 30s now how much do you
weigh now I'm at okay so I hit 150 and
now I'm back down to like I think 145
yeah I was a hundred and forty pounds or
in the fifth grade
no but the [ __ ] is now when I [ __ ]
gain weight oh oh hey here man have you
seen that you seen it everybody shocked
they're like where the [ __ ] did that
come from because you look like et she
was so weird I'm like I'm so skinny
everywhere else but Loki got like a
little gut and so like when I pull that
[ __ ] out people think it's fake like
what the post I just don't understand
the whole one bite left over thing like
I'll never understand that [ __ ] how dare
you use styrofoam for that how they're
gonna make the waitress go back ask for
[ __ ] styrofoam of forks and paper oh
here's another stupid isn't it
Hey look that is
hello Emily
is that an ambulance this dude - he also
has like this certain level of OCD oh
yeah so I'm only saying this stuff
because we're talking about going out to
eat he does this thing with napkins and
also infuriates me
he can't once he'd use it once the
napkin touches his lips it's done yeah
it's completely done
he can't fold it use another side of the
napkin it's one white gun okay I to be
fair I can use the other side but only
one side so okay let's say I get it
wipe I could do the other side wipe
that's it because here's my logic is
that there is no logic there's nothing
that you could say it's a mental defect
that I know because my thing is that why
are you using napkins to clean yourself
right so why the [ __ ] would you want to
keep using a site that you already use
like if you have grease on your mouth
you want to wipe that [ __ ] off and then
use a clean site right speaking of that
that's why I [ __ ] hate in and out
napkins man
it's like [ __ ] 2019 you put the
[ __ ] napkins on the side don't put it
over the cheeseburger and let the grease
and the cheese and the [ __ ] special
sauce soak into that [ __ ] I can't even
use it you know so it's like there's
some weird who [ __ ] cares man I said
it's an in-and-out burger okay let me
tell you something right now man if an
in-and-out burger comes out that
delicious delicious burger comes under
the first thing you think about is
goddamn these napkins because that's the
first thing is you're gonna be a serial
killer dude those are facts you sure
it's not a shoe salesman yes yeah so we
got you so you guys remember Z from the
for the podcast earlier Z Z since we've
known him since day one he has like so
he because he's from Sweden
you know we forget sometimes because it
was just so damn good we forget that he
doesn't know a lot of like either
American things yeah or he doesn't he
has his habit of mixing things together
that just doesn't [ __ ] make sense but
he says it with like the utmost
confidence like what he was like dad I
could really go for some cantaloupe a
cantaloupe a we were at a 7-eleven one
time and then I was looking at Twinkies
and it's nice thinking about getting
some is I owe those are the yum Yum's
right I'm like oh what is like though so
the yum Yum's
Oh what are you looking at what are the
yum yum you said that I'm like these are
[ __ ] Twinkies bro what do you mean yo
yum yum but I don't know man I think he
like he takes I know there's a yum-yum
doughnut yeah mate so that's what I
thought I thought maybe he's just like
taking what he saw and it's just kind of
getting jumbled up in his head and that
automatically becomes associated with a
certain thing you know does that [ __ ]
too
really that some people would just
second-guess what they're saying ya know
I actually have like in my phone I wrote
a lot of stuff that Mariel says yeah I
can't find this in my iPhone that's
that's what we said we were gonna do
with Z like we're gonna keep a list of
all alright so what we were talking
about right now about the shoe salesman
is uh yesterday I was talking about I
was talking about the new document'
docu-series on a netflix about Ted Bundy
he's a serial killer and then so I
brought that up and he he was like wait
what this shoe salesman and I was like
no whoo oh my this will thought we were
talking about my children and he says it
was such confidence dude and he says
it's so confidently that you have to
kind of stop and think about it for a
second like am I am I am I am i confused
right now but yeah this guy is like he
just has these weird ways of like
processing I think certain things yeah
and then he makes us second-guess it to
when we've been living here longer than
it was so stupid he goes let's go go oh
he goes oh dude I [ __ ] love Rhode
Island sauce brought it up to show me
like it exists I'm like but you didn't
say as if you knew it existed yeah I
know exactly he's referring to a
Thousand Islands he goes you let me have
some of that Rhode Island sauce I was
like what did you just say to me dude I
will slap the [ __ ] out of you why are
you saying
I wish I could remember like all the
[ __ ] ridiculous cause him a LOI black
kind of like hello because he black I
remember that [ __ ] cuz I came back from
Hawaii yeah he goes you should use that
a LOI I'll say oh what's that
because I I thought it was some kind of
like unique product right he goes oh use
a LOI for that it's gonna be really good
I said what he goes oh yeah oh let me
look that up because how you spell it
he goes a l a lo [ __ ] oh yeah oh my god
so yeah I mean we love this guy though
well he might be right because people
and when I was in kawaii this that's
what they would say to go al away oh
really a boy or something like that I've
heard I was at like this pokey
marketplace yeah yeah and they told me I
should use a lawyer no but that he's not
that's not that's not his point of
reference stuff but he would use that in
his defense though hazy learn here so
[ __ ] English we actually have one of
our friends that we actually met him
through Z his name yo check this
[ __ ] out on YouTube mr. Stowell
so it's so funny to cuz when we met him
he wasn't in the shoes at all yeah and I
think he got into shoes because II was
in tissues and I think from then he just
started to I don't know whatever piqued
his interest for it but he just started
to like shoes out of nowhere
yeah and then he started doing his own
sneaker reviews yo shout-out to it you
know it's his sneaker reviews to me I
know it's not he's not trying to be
funny but it makes me it makes me laugh
I know it's very serious but it's
something about it yeah what do you
first see you used to do these sneaker
reviews this [ __ ] used to dress
up mister stolen so before his YouTube
even had subscribers this full brought
out Burch [ __ ] love this guy did you
know this guy was a man
but you know what props to him because
the dedication o discipline because like
you know anytime somebody starts
something on YouTube you obviously not
gonna get that much views right you're
not gonna get that much attention but
then to not let that deter you from like
right I want to do this so I'm gonna
keep doing it he's a he's a classic
version of what I call somebody who
creates to create because they enjoy it
yeah right yeah and we don't actually
see a lot of that nowadays we see a lot
of people who do something and because
it doesn't fulfill the need of other
people giving you an external validation
saying that you're doing something
amazing Yemen that they'll stop what
they're doing with this guy I think he
genuinely loves doing absolutely because
he hasn't stopped did I mean how many
years has it been though all [ __ ] time
without fail I don't think he's like
missed an episode I think he's been
consistently uploading you know way more
consistent than idea and you know what
that has so much to do with like what
people want out of life you know they
can say like oh I'll do anything that I
need to do in order to get to where I
need to get to because that's what I
believe in or that's what I want to do
but as soon as that hardwork settles in
different story they're singing a
different tune after that and you know
for even a guy like it like he's not
like a huge youtuber but like you said
he's passionate about what he does or he
enjoys it at least on some level and to
just have that kind of discipline to
because I'm sure there are days where
he's just like [ __ ] dude I mean we were
talking about the other day too and he
was talking to me about how it's hard to
stay motivated sometimes yeah you know
doing the same thing over and over and I
was just telling him like when you
create content you have to figure out a
way to make it fun for you because at
the other day it just starts to feel
like a nine-to-five job and if you were
gonna work a nine-to-five job you should
have just done that in the first place
yeah man it's kind of us up to us as
creators to really figure out how to
make this fun yeah you know it's beyond
just a regular living and and maybe some
maybe it's a little hard to understand
it's it's very difficult to be
constantly the master of your own
destiny with even within your career
right because sometimes when people work
nine to five jobs like I know a lot of
friends who work these jobs where they
do it and they just shut off and they
become a robot yeah yeah and their
creative time is is off yeah
those times yeah but one
comes to being a creative in your career
space it's just non-stop and I think
that's also one of the bigger reasons
why it's hard for me to sleep it's hard
for you to sleep because my mind doesn't
shut off exactly like and sometimes - at
night some of the best ideas come during
that time that's the that's that's what
I call the [ __ ] you know primetime
like yeah for me I get the best thinking
done I think from 12 a.m. on and
especially in this show I [ __ ] hate
it I hate that [ __ ] cuz I want to sleep
I don't know but you know what man I've
just learned to accept it because that's
how I've been for so long I'm just like
you know what it's just it's just me
alright there's not why fight it and I
will take like sleep aids to try to help
myself sleep a little bit earlier but
I'm just like well if I don't stay up at
that time then I might not have these
ideas that I would have had otherwise if
I did just stay up but that's the thing
man like have you ever thought about
though if you had lived your life in a
more conventional way right have you do
you like some 100% I would be in jail
because I killed somebody I would have
been a serial I'm not saying I wouldn't
be thought I would be a serial killer I
would have lost my I would have lost my
[ __ ] Maya because even Muriel knows
me now as a person who hates habit right
hate I know habitual thing right I'd
like I'm what Charlie I'm a habitual
line stepper dude like you tell me to do
something I'm breaking that [ __ ] yeah
it's just who I am as a person you know
back in the day you know what I used to
build IKEA [ __ ] yeah I would there would
be this IKEA thing and when you open up
an Ikea a manual or that teach you an
instruction on how to build something
how it always starts off is it's this
white dude big ass [ __ ] yeah and then
you see it with a beret and then he's
trying to build it but they go X and
don't just build it with one princess
three yeah then I go [ __ ] you you don't
see imma do it right problem is you can
do it by yourself here's the problem it
takes 12 hours because I went through
the exact service dude there was this
red shelf that I built from Ariel that
we actually just sold on offer up yeah
and she was like what you built this for
me and the first thing I said when she
said that I said [ __ ]
that thing good I built that [ __ ] so I
built the the drawers yeah and you know
how they have like the rail thing but I
was so exhausted I [ __ ] put that [ __ ]
on the inside for some reason I built
the whole shelf and had to dismantle the
whole thing and it took me four hours to
build it man I had a dismantle that
whole thing and rebuild it again and
when I was done it was slightly crooked
oh and so it kind of rocked that would a
[ __ ] German I lost my [ __ ] mind
you know I know you're OCD but I have a
little bit of what you have yeah yeah so
right now I moved into a new apartment
in Glendale and because the rooms a
little smaller we decide to use these
standing shoe shelves instead so you
could actually fold it so I'm doing this
whole Marie Kondo thing trying to live a
little more minimal and so the shoe
shelves work really well because you can
fold it and it kind of slides in and you
can grab them out really easy yeah so I
bought the big one and I also bought a
small one that'll stay in front of my
bed frame mm-hmm so I could put like
socks or whatever in there yeah and same
shelf it's it the knobs are different on
the smaller and you still have the red
shelf too I built the whole [ __ ] bit
huh and I write when I saw the front of
it I was like what is with the color of
this knob and then Merida was like oh no
and I built it and I was living took me
four hours yeah and I saw it and she
goes she looked at me dead in my eye
shadows returning that to me and I said
what do you think what do you think if
we have it I'm gonna [ __ ] break this
[ __ ] so literally I'm in bed I'm cursing
up a storm about the dumbest thing I'm
like you [ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ] IKEA
put that [ __ ] in the wrong [ __ ] bin
can [ __ ] deal with this [ __ ] and
she's just like trying to calm me down
[ __ ]
all right stop being a little baby you
know but that's the thing that people
don't understand of like when they don't
have that is like yeah you know that's
the thing man it's like okay if you
can't understand it that's one thing but
try to respect it at least you know
because I'm not trying to impose that on
you or you don't want to live like this
it's John I know it's like that not that
we're choosing to [ __ ] be like this
if I could just let things go like that
God my life would be so much [ __ ] he
there was a point in my life when I went
grocery
shopping I'd have to go through every
[ __ ] aisle I would go to buy like
some bread right in my head I'm thinking
I'm gonna buy some bread and eggs right
and then I [ __ ] wasted our and cuz I
have to go through each up because in my
head I'm thinking well I might need
something in this aisle so I gotta take
a look you know I don't know how you're
gonna get married dude I think I think
what's gonna happen is if you ever get
married you know the kid kids with the
Daiya starvation is all he wanted was
some milk and [ __ ] hands dad stayed in
the grocery store for seven hours but
you know what though as I got older
because I here's the thing you know I'm
a like very logical and reasonable
person and so I completely recognize
that this is [ __ ] ridiculous my
tendencies that I have right
so I phased out definitely certain I
guess tics that I had because I used to
have a thing where things on my desk
needed to be perpendicular like so this
[ __ ] would need to be like 90 degrees
with here you know everything and if
somebody moved that [ __ ] I'll be like
what the [ __ ] are you doing and I would
fix it like what I'm like you [ __ ]
move my laptop really [ __ ] go to
school with the suitcase then so you
could organize things in straight lines
you definitely didn't have a chance or
backpack because when you put something
in a JanSport backpack the way it came
in and came out was way different
no no just like on my personal desk at
home oh yeah I needed to be arranged
that way and then it wasn't until like I
think I was in my early 20s or somebody
was like dude you have OCD yeah and then
it was like it never occurred to me that
I was everybody's crazy no in my mind I
just thought that's just the way things
have to be and I and never is your
parents like that your house to [ __ ]
they're not you know they're not like
that at all so I don't think your mom's
[ __ ] food is good dude
like shout out to moms you know yeah I'm
surprised because I'm usually very picky
about other Korean moms Korean food yeah
and I usually don't like it as much as
my mom yeah of course my mom's just
preferred cuz I grew up with it but like
I it's weird for me to eat another
Korean mom's food and be like it's just
[ __ ] good yeah cuz usually what
happens is when somebody tells me that
their mom can cook yeah nothing good
right I mean everybody likes to say
their mom's food is the best food but
like when I say it it's not just a
an opinion other people say yeah other
people like our family members they love
coming to our place relatives and stuff
because if they know my mom's cookin
they're like oh [ __ ] is gonna be a good
dinner it's weird too because home cooks
usually don't care about aesthetics
right
and your mom's aesthetics on her food is
on point yeah it's because my mom
doesn't give a [ __ ] about aesthetics
yeah it tastes amazing yeah your mom has
aesthetic she's about plating the way it
looks yeah like her kimbap was perfect
yeah so we shot JK news the other day
and then uh like I I had met up with my
pops right before and then she like my
mom sent like a thing of kimbap with him
so for those of you who don't know what
that is it's kind of like seaweed
wrapped in rice with like vegetables and
meat instead it's like Korean sushi whoo
yeah pretty much but it's not made as
like a dining type of thing yeah for us
we call it poetic which is art like to
go right right like our lunch pail type
of snack it's typically you'll see it a
lot in like Korean cocina yeah and then
so I just shared it because I had it
with everybody that was there and then
um I knew how was it gonna taste because
I've had it all my life but you know
that's a thing it [ __ ] me up though
because I grew up eating that so I was
spoiled with good food that's probably
like the only thing I was spoiled with
and then it was hard for me to want to
eat out like at Korean restaurants today
for it cuz I'm like dude I know my mom's
it would taste better of course and I
don't I don't want to pay for something
that I feels inferior you know so
whenever people would be like hey let's
go eat out of cream rush I'm like yeah
I'll just meet you snappy there's like
specialty Korean restaurants that
definitely makes food better than my
mom's right because a lot of the stuff
that my mom makes I say like half of its
kind of like more the instant stuff yeah
yeah for them if they're gonna be
artisanal about it yeah what's gonna be
better than my mom yeah like they have
like for example like if they're gonna
do like I don't know like that's special
like chicken [ __ ] no I'm not gonna go
that far to me yeah like rice porridge
like rice porridge is like poor folks
foods when you're sick yeah you know I
mean it's not gonna go ahead and do the
chef's artisanal route for that yeah so
of course there's gonna be better but
you know just like simple if you like my
mom's kimchi my poop on town or side
dishes yeah well even mom's making
kimchi I feel like is such a rare thing
now cuz a lot of times it'll just be
store-bought they don't want to go
through that process doesn't do the napa
cabbage wanted oh yes she does like oil
kimchi there's like the the Pegeen she
could do it in smaller batches yeah but
because like number one it was it was a
church of anything so when my mom used
to make kimchi and kimchi for those who
don't know it's a fermented cabbage it's
napa cabbage that's fermented with fish
sauce sesame seeds soy sauce sea salt
yeah and red pepper flakes a lot of
mother different variation sometimes
you'll see squid in they're not gonna go
really into it but when my parents would
do it it was a big event
yeah so they would give their homegirls
or whatever and they would all sit down
together and they would make a fat batch
and everybody would take their batch
home so the problem with that is a lot
of ahjumma's would stop doing it because
all their kids left the house so who's
gonna eat all that yeah that's right so
they wouldn't make it anymore and so my
mom I just remember as a kid watching
all the ladies come to out my parents
house and my mom and them would make fat
batches of kimchi and everybody would
take their stuff yeah cuz yeah dude it's
like so much work already done for them
you know so [ __ ] good yeah and my mom
too so back in the day even like unless
you get like really good supermarket
kimchi it doesn't taste that good
so because of doing it very basic yeah
I'm not really going above and beyond
we're not really like there's no love in
it you know what I mean yeah you know
and sometimes like the great thing about
home cooking is that it does taste
different every time it has there's like
sometimes a little salt here sometimes
it's not you know I mean cuz like you
know sometimes I'll like get my mom's
recipe for something simple right
something I can make at home fairly
easily and then I make it and it just
doesn't taste today man like I had like
I just bought some kimchi today because
I make kimchi to get yeah but I ate it
no it's good but the the biggest
difference is it's not made with my
mom's kimchi
yeah so that's that's like the main
ingredient too so yeah it doesn't really
have that that stank to it that I
normally like and so when it like my mom
one time to this is during the time
where you really couldn't get a lot of
great Supermarket stuff mm-hmm
or the kimchi just wasn't that good yeah
I came back from college and then my mom
put out this plate of kimchi and I ate
it and they go the hell is this mm-hmm
she was like but I was like you to make
this terrible what is like how did you
know that I was like seems like trash to
me this it is like you don't think I
know the difference between yours and
you know somebody else so flavorless
yeah
what would you eat this I just didn't
have enough time well you don't have to
make it yeah I still want to eat this
you don't have to take offense to it
yeah it's not like you made it saying
like you don't have to get it for me
yeah just bad nobody thing like with the
presentation thing with my mom she's
really good with her hands like she's
really good at arts and crafts yeah so I
wish she would just open up a restaurant
I know it's a lot of work but yeah do it
but people have been telling her for
like I don't know I would say most of
her adult life like you need to open up
a restaurant right but we had a family
friend that owned a restaurant before
and like when they were first starting
out she went out there to help them out
and I don't think she'd be able to
handle it just a lot of work yeah just
on the day-to-day you know I wasn't
thinking so much that she could do like
maybe a restaurant restaurant she could
do like Korean pentose oh I see you know
Kim Bob right got sued right other stuff
and like just that alone cuz she could
make that in batches yeah and it would
be so [ __ ] I would buy that [ __ ] dude my
mom's a [ __ ] hustler man like you
know when when we were like struggling
and [ __ ] she would make different types
of katsu like so shrimp pork beef
chicken and then she would make him in
like big batches and then freeze all of
them and then like it was fry it on the
spot right yeah well-known unlike the
neighborhood moms and like friends of
friends they would hear about it and
then you know a lot of them don't want
to make a lot of work yeah so like they
would just buy it for the kids and then
even like a small local market started
picking up on it you know so I know that
she does make good food but you know I
just feel like now that she's a little
bit older too it would be even harder
for her to do that on like a big scale
because back then she was like in her
40s yeah yeah so it's a little bit more
manageable but now mom no she's 61 oh
she's good yeah yeah as you can see I
have my parents genes they both like you
[Laughter]
imagine yeah is really good cuz I
remember your parents were asking like
the one we're going to come over and eat
yeah yeah and to be honest with you I
was expecting much how much she prepped
the puffy stone and she was soulful
because I had been home in a while
that's true that's true
it was that it was nice to have a
home-cooked curry milanesa with and it's
interesting cuz your dad was a demeanor
is the complete opposite of your mom
right yeah I mean your dad's cool and
everything else but yeah it does have a
hard exterior yeah he does he does and
your mom has this like very flowery like
song poofy warmth so so you know the the
thing is like my mom both of my parents
are pretty social but you're not gonna
really get that from I guess first
impression when you see my dad cause
like you said first appearances he does
have like a more harder exterior he's
look like he's killed a few people who
like Averell real [ __ ] man he he when he
when we were [ __ ] had a little store
in south-central right yeah like it was
a crib neighborhood and so like a lot of
people will come there and because he's
Asian they would you know make jokes
yeah yeah and like one time one guy got
really obnoxious and he was a gangbanger
right my dad like because he that there
was a counter and it was a little
slightly elevated and then so like the
customer kind of had to look up huh you
[ __ ] put his foot on the counter
start tying shoes he was I was they
thought he knew karate for reals yeah he
saw like my dad was tying his shoelaces
and he's like we're gonna fight
he thought Oh mother this [ __ ]
guy really knows karate man if I was if
I was that age back I would have took
full advantage of that ignorance too
like before I went to work I would just
get like two by fours it I would saw
them a little bit have a she body break
it on my forehead just to show them and
just had us come out you know this guy
know some crazy [ __ ] exactly so like I
don't think too many people try to [ __ ]
with him and you know he had guns yeah
like one time I was out there and I
don't remember his story but my pops
told me like there was this lady who was
like buying something is like you know
just his friendly lady and then he said
I was standing there and all of a sudden
I take the gun from underneath the
counter and slammed it on the table in
foot and she was he like freaked out and
my dad what are you doing I was like I
don't know because I think I didn't have
a concept of like how lethal yeah guys
yeah that gun is and to me it was just
like I think it's cool
right I just kind of pulled it out and
slammed it on the table and then I guess
she almost like had a heart attack why
would a damn heart attack it's like what
the [ __ ] I'm just a customer oh I don't
know it's a good one one memory that I
have is like you know the zig zags you
know there's like an old like keep like
Jewish lick and dude on there like his
grandpa with the beard or whatever I
thought it was Jesus and so I asked my
pops
why is Jesus smoke and my parents aren't
religious so he's just like what are you
talking about like that isn't that Jesus
oh my god dude I didn't know that is
remembered every time I think about like
liquor stores it's not the only thing I
remember or I think about the first
thing that comes to mind is the smell of
like black and milds info yeah I think
great Swisher's not used all day bro
they would come in and buy that [ __ ]
like his is like crack you know cuz they
smell so good though yeah I used to
smoke black amongst black and mounts -
this is a black mushroom yeah yeah yeah
but you know what the Swisher's is so
you know yeah of course yeah yeah but
then they started like selling the paper
and [ __ ] so yeah yeah a lot easier they
didn't have to yeah I remember one time
two men like this dude walked in this is
like my pops is in Compton and then he
had all tatted on his [ __ ] forehead I
think it was like f 13 some some like I
don't know faction of like the Mexican
Mafia I remember looking at him is like
yeah this guy made his choice in laughs
it was like this big on his [ __ ]
forehead you know pretty much
advertising and broadcasting like yeah
this is what I am I'm like you have to
really be you know I can't even get a
regular tattoo man
I can't commit to that [ __ ] I can't
because I'm OCD oh you'd be game over
dude yeah II would have to be
perpendicular to your veins or [ __ ] but
you know what if there's one person that
I would get it from is Jun cha you know
you know who that is his Instagram is
pretty crazy right yeah he's like yeah
like this [ __ ] yeah
you're to get like yeah if not longer
and he's like expensive as [ __ ] and the
thing is it's like the first time I'd
heard about him was through like a
friend's friend and I guess she went to
art school with him or something and and
she was like oh yeah this guy went to
art school with his like kind of coming
up in the tattoo world and at that time
his deposit and like wait time was
minimal you know
it wasn't he wasn't anybody in there he
was still [ __ ] great though even back
then when he's not a name yeah I don't
have a name that was gonna pay for this
[ __ ]
yeah so I was just kind of like I don't
know and then a year went by two years
went by and you started to [ __ ] blow
up and I was like fine regret that [ __ ]
I should have done it you would have got
a a jute towel original Jintao is the
different shower oh yes what I bet you
can tell you we got a dude towel
original dude I said it was it tight as
[ __ ] that would have it but yeah well
anyways guys we just hit about an hour
mhm yeah I don't remember what the [ __ ]
we live no we're gonna call this podcast
in this episode it's called Edgar's poor
choices my poor choices in life
learn from it what you gotta take away
from it is Stacey I miss you we'll call
her Susan okay he misses you anyways
guys remember you guys can fight is odd
you know a lot of people keep asking
this Angela how come you're not on
Spotify [ __ ] all you have to do is look
it up on Spotify it's right there I'm so
sick of that [ __ ] god dammit just
kidding I love you Spotify we're talking
about I tooth podcast yeah we're talking
about stitcher we're talking about
Kasbah oh he's just like they're like no
I know how come you're not on cat is
like Spotify yeah just kind of type it
in did you even check
did you just place you guys check on it
oh you know what it is it's probably
this genius brain is one word oh yeah
completely different but anyways thank
you guys very much appreciate you so
much Adric where can they find you on
Instagram add to EDT wo and then also
visit the site secret society com that's
s c RT s o CI e py yeah a secret society
we're actually gonna come out with a so
real quick are we gonna make the
announcement right now yeah all right
just because do the honors my friend is
gonna put a beat on ourselves right now
so
that two one three collection is
basically a representation of LA and so
for the first small capsule collection
we're doing we're doing a k-town release
so be ready for that in like the next
month or so so yes sir all right Chelsey
all right peace yo